what are you doing here welcome back
everyone its charlie we have a whole
bunch of Batman crisis on Infinite
Earths Easter eggs to talk about Kevin
Conroy Batman and Michael Keaton Batman
Easter eggs that's right they're even
including Michael Keaton Batman stuff
during this year's crossover so I'll
explain what those Easter eggs are and
how this all fits in and there's a whole
bunch of other previews that we've
gotten in the last week so I'll talk
about those two we're doing a brand new
Joker giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite version of Batman on the video
breaking all this stuff down top-five
style number 5 the two versions of
Batman that we know about there might
actually be more versions of Batman that
they referenced during the crossover but
we only have two confirmed ones right
now not including the one from the
Batwoman TV show so I guess you could
say that there's three versions of
Batman we have the Kevin Conroy Batman
that we already know about they've
confirmed they're filming the second
episode of the crossover right now which
is the Batwoman episode makes sense that
they would have Batman walking around on
set for the Batwoman episode as you can
see he's let his facial hair grow out
for his scenes so it seems like it's a
more beaten down version of Batman from
Batman the Animated Series and Batman
Beyond in real life Kevin Conroy is only
about 63 years old he's not that old
his older version of Batman during
Batman Beyond was in his 80s but because
he's Batman and he's this mythical
figure even though it looks like he's
walking around with a cane he's still
very powerful as this frail looking old
man but he doesn't look that frail the
reason why I keep referencing Batman in
the animated series and Batman Beyond is
because when they bring on an actor
that's played another version of a
character from another TV show or
another movie they try to canonize the
events of that show or movie to the
arrowverse like when you have the
Smallville actors like Tom Welling and
Erica Durance on you canonized
Smallville to the arrowverse
we also saw Burt Ward walking around on
set lbc he's much older in real life now
but he's playing a much older version of
his Robin from the 1966 series he's even
wearing a Robin looking sweater so count
that as four versions of Batman now
because if he was Robin on that show it
means that he had his Adam West's Batman
meaning that there canonizing the 1966
Batman TV series to the arrowverse
that's how crazy it's getting now I've
talked a little bit about Batman Beyond
becoming cannon to the arrowverse and a
lot of people have asked what they're
gonna do with Terry McGinnis if they're
gonna try and do that character at some
point on these shows I don't know what
the rules behind that are there was a
long time ago before the Christopher
Nolan Dark Knight trilogy when Warner
Brothers was developing a live-action
Batman Beyond movie but it never really
made it past the planning stages but at
one point after the Joel Schumacher era
has sort of salted the earth of Batman
they thought about reinvigorating the
franchise by doing it differently with a
Batman Beyond character my expectations
for Kevin Conroy Batman during the
crossover are that he'll give sage
advice but because he's got that five
o'clock shadow going on he's probably a
much more world-weary cynical version of
Batman at this point otherwise he would
be more clean-shaven he'd be a little
happier looking number four talking
about Michael Keaton Batman involvement
so obviously nobody expects Michael
Keaton to do one of these TV shows but
what happened recently is that there was
this Easter egg that was spotted on set
it was a Gotham City Gazette newspaper
that looks like it's an old newspaper
reading waynetech CEO Bruce Wayne to
marry socialite Selina Kyle and there it
is bright as day Michael Keaton's Bruce
Wayne so obviously this means that
they're canonizing the events of his
Batman movies Batman in Batman Returns
to the arrowverse which is fantastic but
I have a couple other theories about
what they're doing with this because
even though Michael Keaton might not be
walking around on set being Batman
during the crossover they can use the
character in any kind of story way that
they want they might be using him as an
Easter Egg for the backstory for
Huntress from the birds of prey TV show
because that actress really will be in
the crossover and her parents were a
version of Bruce Wayne and a version of
Selina Kyle Catwoman the only bad thing
about this picture from the set is that
you can't actually read the date on the
newspaper that would actually help quite
a bit but I'm assuming they're trying to
say did this happen
during the late 80s early 90s around the
events of those movies the other really
big easter egg that a lot of you
probably spotted is that it says
waynetech CEO which is an easter egg
paying off the flash future newspaper
going back to the very first episode
saying waynetech queen incorporated
merger complete as if to say yes that
was happening on earth 1 because the
future newspaper was about the history
of the earth that Barry is from but it
also probably wound up happening on the
earth that Michael Keaton's Batman will
be from if that's not going to be earth
one it would be fantastic though if they
did say that earth ones Batman was
Michael Keaton the Batwoman TV show does
take place on earth one but we've never
seen an actual picture of who that
Batman was they just say that he took
off and he was never seen again and he's
been gone for the last couple of years
from the way they shot that TV show the
set design made to look like The Dark
Knight version of Gotham City their
version of Batman
seemed like he was going to be a
Christian Bale Batman crossed with Adam
West Batman but I'm kind of expecting
that TV show to combine elements from
all different versions of Batman because
they're not really allowed to have the
character on screen so they can kind of
do whatever they want to with them so
that's why they're just having fun with
a lot of different types of Easter eggs
obviously I'm stoked to see Kevin Conroy
get to play a live-action version of
Batman but I'm even more excited that
they're able to do all this Michael
Keaton Batman stuff I would have never
expected they could do something like
this number 3 though the picture of all
those heroes assembled on the Waverider
that you probably saw in the last couple
of days there's a lot of comic book
Easter eggs here we have brain and raus
Kingdom Come Superman Tyler hoechlin
earth 38 Superman Tom Cavanagh as the
pariah character from the crisis on
Infinite Earths comics another alternate
version of Harrison wells in the context
of the arrowverse in an alternate
version of Lyla whose Harbinger from the
crisis on Infinite Earths comics pariah
was a scientist from an alternate earth
who made the mistake of trying to meddle
in affairs that he wasn't supposed to so
obviously Grand consequences imagine mad
scientist's creating this crazy
experiment that goes completely off the
rails he was trying to see the dawn of
the multiverse and in doing so he caused
a chain reaction that inadvertently
alerted the anti-monitor in his
antimatter universe to the existence of
the positive matter multiverse
so pariah became the character that
everybody blamed for the dead
of billions in billions of people across
the multiverse that was what the monitor
was referring to at the end of the flash
season six episode one when he was
talking to Barry in order for billions
to survive this coming crisis flash died
so it's on Barry shoulders to save all
these people because a flash has to die
they didn't say that Barry has to die
they just say a flash has to die so
remember that but everybody blames Paria
for them getting into this situation in
the first place because Tom Cavanaugh is
a series regular on the flash TV show
and plays all these different versions
of Harrison wells season 2 season
obviously this is going to be an
alternate version of Harrison wells that
they'll introduce during the flash
season 6 in a future episode in fact
during flash season 1 episode 2 Harrison
wells who secretly reverse-flash also
dropped a pariah Easter Egg when he was
talking about his wheelchair but I don't
know if that was on purpose
or just a coincidence I doubt restraint
is how you got to be the man you are
today in a wheelchair and a pariah lack
of restraint is what made me these
things will give him the benefit of the
doubt and say that they planned that arm
purpose knowing that they would turn him
into the pariah character eventually
someday Harbinger is just a servant of
the monitor in the comics she follows
him around as he's traveling around
trying to assemble all the heroes to
fight the anti-monitor they did have an
Easter Egg for this during arrow season
1 when they introduced the Lila
character her code name was Harbinger on
a mission number 2 then we have Black
Lightning in his brand new costume so if
you don't watch The Black Lightning TV
show they gave him a brand new costume
this season and obviously its present
day when he crosses over to crisis on
Infinite Earths the other really
important brand new character in the
background here that you probably
recognize is ostrich Chow from the
supernatural TV show he's playing Ryan
choy the new version of the atom that's
going to be joining legends of tomorrow
this season if you've been watching the
flash the last couple of seasons - one
of the big Easter eggs for Ryan Choi is
he's the person who helped miniaturize
the flash ring technology so the flash
ring that Barry is wearing right now was
made by Ryan Choi in the future this is
obviously him in present-day before he
does that though they haven't explained
how they're going to introduce him but
he's basically taking the spot of ray
Palmer's atom on the
legends of tomorrow team because Brandon
Ralph is leaving the show in real life
this season just like Tom Cavanagh is
playing reverse-flash during the
crossover and also the pariah character
Brandon Roth is doing the same thing
where he plays a couple different
characters the other really big rumor
that was being reported earlier today is
that Lucifer's Tom Ellis was spotted on
the set where they're filming the
crossover making people think that
Lucifer will be in this year's crisis on
Infinite Earths
so everybody post your theories in the
comments below and let me know what you
want them to do with Michael Keaton
Batman if they can use his character but
they're not gonna have Michael Keaton
himself inside the episodes there's a
whole bunch of videos I'm working out
I'll try to get them out as fast as
possible leave all your requests and big
questions in the comments everybody
click here for that brand new Suicide
Squad to preview and first look and
click here for my Joker movie ending
scene and Easter egg videos thank you so
much for watching everybody put on a
happy face I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]